[music] d protect [music]
cn please be the proprietress
[music]
[music] It's
already time
thank you
In the last 10 years, I haven't felt like my life was in danger, but
about 2 years ago, I was at this hospital
.
If it's
such an exaggerated
[music], I
'll die already 6
Yes, I'll remember it and send it to you
Oh
, I'm a person like Yagi
.
Don't underestimate Yagi, who looks at you and makes you feel vital
I bought a guy with hair that I fell in love with at first sight
Oh, even back then, that girl wasn't wearing a beret, but you're trying to prevent assistants and
identify them
Ah, I'm not good at remembering girls' faces now, and I
remember a lot  I'm
Kotoko Iwanaga. I'm Kotoko Iwanaga.
I'm 17 years old
.
I heard you broke up with Ms. What are
you doing again,
Mr. Sasaki
?
There is also the possibility of the
4th My
name is Kuro Sakuragawa and I'm a second year student in the law department of Komei University.I'm in
the hospital for a long time
.
She's a year older than
me, and I've been dating since high school, and it's been hard
for me.  You said you were going to get married
Oh,
I heard you introduced me to your parents the
other day.  Scheduled cancer
Today I
'm alone. Didn't you break up
with her?
I wonder
what's going on.You said that you don't have an obligation to protect the things of those who are visiting you, but that's kind of
suspicious, isn't it?
No, but
it's better if you don't know
The reason for the long-term hospitalization is usually uninteresting
Is it the story of how Dezaki-san and I broke up this spring?
Are you interested in opening a new store with new encounters? Can
you summarize the main points
?
]
You're direct despite your appearance
Waiting for 2 years is kind of boring, but
destiny can wait
Dating junior high school students is like a
morning assembly
That's why I'm 17 and high school student next year  I'm planning to take entrance exams for a university where I'm going to a university
where I'm
in a good mood Your memory is a chicken navigation car  Did you get dumped? It's not
Saki-san's fault.There
was no hitter,
so new relationships wo
n't be possible for a while.Eh, what specifically caused the breakup to become disgraceful?At
the end of last year, Saki and I played Kyoto power
It's a whole trip, you're sloppy
You're one of those eras So when you're
walking along the Kamo River late at night
, it's said that you'll appear at that
waterside  It was something that was appropriate to call.
Sure,
it wasn't a human or an animal.
Kappa isn't a bad thing these days
.
I'm a shy guy
The next
day, a living body was discovered around there.It was deemed an accident, but the
cause remains
unknown.Saki-san, who doesn't believe in ghosts, let alone ghosts, seems to have hair growing in her heart.
After clinging to me,
what happened?
I didn't look at Saki-san
like that, I ran away like a rabbit with my voice trembling with fear. Well, it's
cold weather.
It's a story that he broke up with you when you left here
for a job.I don't care if you believe it or not.
I'm a college student who went crazy from the shock of being shocked Either way, I don't think he's suitable for your boyfriend It's
almost time for the bus Oh, the
story isn't over yet
It was the kappa who ran away, not you. The
kappa saw you next to Saki and was frightened and ran away.
I guarantee that Saki-san would run away just by seeing that hideous specter. Who would you be?
It's no wonder you said you were there earlier, but that's a
lie I don't tell girls about my
heartbreak honestly  Yokai Yokai,
or
simply so-called monsters, are lurking in
the shadows of the azaleas in this garden,
whispering to us from the tops of the flowering trees
.  They look at you and whisper to me They're different They
're scary
Who are they in the city?
I was kidnapped
deep in the mountains, and they asked
me to become the god of our wisdom.
I'm looking for someone who will lend us our strength and take out the conflict without asking
After that, when disputes and problems arose, those people came
from all over the country to seek arbitration and solutions.
It's hard, but this is six years ago,
so please check the newspaper around July. In this town,
Kotoko Iwanaga, a
5th grade elementary school girl, went missing, and two weeks later
she was warming herself up on a park bench.
[MUSIC] The
girl had her left leg amputated and her
right eye gouged out
.  I'm going to
dash
due to
[music]
I put me in
There's
no such thing as the total  You didn't touch me
by what part of the stinky and horrible mixture is good?
It was stolen like a
tress either.
If you get close to the heir to the person who is touching you, please take good care of your love in front of you.
In Kojiki, which is said to be a document,
the name of the god Kuebiko is written.It is said that although
it cannot walk on one leg, it is
a god of wisdom who knows Yeonu well.The
first one is also sometimes a god
or  It's said that it was treated as something close to that. A
single eye or a pair of hair
can be seen in many rations around the world
.
The third daughter is also hollowed out, but there is
no sea either
.
Can you tell me if you remember anything
Eh,
you mean my left leg and my miserable bloat were for God's sake?
[Music]
Not a bad exchange
I don't remember well
.  Taka
Six years ago, it was true that a girl named Kotoko Iwanaga was involved in an incident,
but that
's
all.  If that's the case, then I'm the girl who was kidnapped by an insane person and had her body groped and gone crazy.Believe it
or not, it's up to you.But maybe I'm the only one in this world who can understand you.
They were sometimes sacrificed to the gods,
or Mikoto was used to connect the gods and people, or to listen to the voice of the gods
.
I'm going to get that feeling I'm constantly checking u Haahaa Even if it's a
voice, I
'm sure you can stop doing this, and I immediately put my hat
on.  It's no good, let's hurry.
The youkai are already ferocious and brutal, and
tomorrow's newspaper may feature an article about a one-eyed, one-legged girl who was massacred by someone.
At the end,
you can't help but feel a sense of
guilt.
On the other hand, Mr. Kuro, calm down, this is the ghost of a fallen warrior.
I'm 1 a
me
car
What should I do with this situation I've cut my tanka?
Was that what you
were looking for? I'm serious about confessing.  It's hard to work with me as a professional
Is there a plan
?  It's definitely bad if it's too expensive me
tee Let's run away for now
Mr. hard work, what's good is that you can't do anything nasty later I'll be in
trouble if Lawson does something unreasonable I didn't like
Lawson
tar
Find out what's wrong How can you be so indifferent to your own danger
?
After all, it seems that my flesh is out
[music]
Hard work
, who the hell are you?
Yes,
to borrow your words 7 When
I was 11 years old, I ate only three types of youkai change me
dnano I
guess it's a story me
go north ana
teame
nani
ane ni
me
me me
I had
me  too
ni
elc
me
kimi ni
[music]
me
Hugh
[music]
me
sooo
voodoo Daide,
the owner of Shounuma, has trouble sleeping at night and asks for advice
The true corpse of the murderer  I threw it away, but
they said they weren't convinced.